Long is, is normally an adjective of some sorts, but that doesn't mean that
every adjective is going to necessarily contribute to this list of attributes.
So, it's fine to have one and then discard it as not being relevant.
Okay? You had single leaf, you have leaf counter.
We have this one set modify sub trees. There is another,
call it a trick, another way of getting modifiers that aren't directly,
that don't correctly come from adjectives, and that is if you've got
a prepositional phrase, such as parts of the tree, or count of the leaves,
you could think of tree parts. Okay? And leave counts and so on. So once again,
the, the, the simple rule of saying adjectives doesn't quite get you all the,
all the way where you want to go. So, some of the issues that arise when you,
when you try this technique. Okay? As we said, parts of the tree doesn't appear.
In, in the natural language to be an adjective. However we still want to
recognize that the word part signifies an attribute of tree. Same for
count of leaves. As you indicated the use of the word long even though it's,
nominally a, an adjective doesn't really contribute here in the sense of
being a modifier for one of these classes. The phrase single leaf,
if we think about it for a minute, has to do with the count of the leaves.
This is a one, of a, of a potential different number of counts that leaves
could have. That is, there's a count attribute that has a value of one.
Okay, single being, single meaning one.
Similar to the phrase two sub trees can be interpreted as a count of
the number of a sub trees, in the tree class. Having a value of two